everybody stop action episode 8 gosh
the first film didn't even have a number
Ryan has written a story that unexpected
but right
[Music]
some of the stuff that happens people
not oh my god
even though I think I know it all they
throw things at me story-wise I never
could have imagined and even though
everybody knows it's the second in the
trilogy it feels like its own thing
car wars are so cool because there's all
these creatures all these amazing visual
effects
like all the characters are also so
complex
Ryan mr. workers cookies out particular
new director convinced Elena walking
sounds
[Music]
it feels like the storylines became more
established the really getting to know
these new characters also with the
characters that we know and love
within their lives change
everything this gave shifted in opposite
way to what the audience expected up to
seven Mayans made Star Wars fresh in new
[Music]
I'm hoping it'll be a little shocking
but I'm hoping it'll feel real and
honest
the fermentation story of it against
evil
holding the most fascinating way but it
had a real spiritual depth today
it's about family and that's what's so
powerful about it
hey youtubers it's a wrap let's break
down all this last Jedi footage so what
happened is d23 did their big panel it's
like a big two-hour disney panel where
they do everything that Disney owns so
that's all the live-action movies
that's Marvel infinity war I'll be doing
a video for that later today so be sure
to subscribe to get all that stuff but
they skipped over all the Han Solo drama
that's been happening it just talked
about last Jedi stuff so it was mostly
behind the scenes they showed in andros
on their infiltration mission they even
hyped up a big rematch between phasma
and finn like oh yeah they're going to
have some crazy action but let's just go
through this shot by shot you see what
looks like the Ock to set this might be
the inside of the cave when they're
filming those interiors now it's not
confirmed or anything but you also have
these shots in the trailer of the
Journal of the Wills this could also be
inside the cave that's on Ock - but
there's no confirmation on that then you
see some first-order architecture this
is unmistakeably from a Star Destroyer
more of the Ock to set these buildings
were actually on that Island before they
filmed there so they just incorporated
this into the idea of the last Jedi
issues at the island where they filmed
these scenes is this ancient religious
retreat people used to go to so it
became this really cool way to
incorporate real-life history and
mythology into the mythology of Star
Wars
Threepio in r2d2 back these look like a
bunch of speeders so they might be from
the casino planet sets which is a big
location in the film I love the way
Anthony Daniels references the fact that
the original Star Wars movie originally
didn't have a number when they released
it in theaters they only added it after
Empire Strikes Back became a thing this
explosion of blood here looks really
awesome but it's actually from that salt
planet you see in the trailer where you
see the speeders dragging the trails it
digs up that dirt red is a huge color in
the movie they use it in the poster it's
typically the signifier for the darkside
this is the lightsaber that Darth Vader
wielded in the original trilogy so
they're using it to sort of highlight
the tone of the film and imply how heavy
things are going to get all the
characters are going to end the movie in
a really bad place
looking like she's on Ock - most of her
behind the scenes are from locations
we've already seen before her sitting on
the Millennium Falcon her training on
awk - with Luke Skywalker her shot of
Finn in his resistance gear out of that
bhakta suit Luke Skywalker in his Jedi
robes I love the way he looks so small
against this cave wall here so this is
probably from that other earlier set
that we were looking at I think when
Daisy Ridley is saying people are going
to go oh my god when they see the movie
it's mostly just the revelations that
are going to offer about the force Mark
Hamill was saying the same thing - about
how they sort of shaped the foundations
of what you think you know about Star
Wars mythology that's probably just tied
to the Journal of the Wills and the idea
that the Jedi had things wrong but CID
had things wrong there's a greater truth
to the force so that's all I'm really
expecting when they're talking about
shaking the foundations of everything
you know first shot of Leia may she rest
in peace she actually looks fantastic in
this film final confirmation that Luke
actually takes Anakin's lightsaber from
Rey although he gives it back to her
because we see her using it in the other
parts of the clip you can just imagine
all the memories flooding into his brain
like I haven't seen this since I got my
hand chopped off by my father
first we'll shot of kylo Ren on a
first-order set he's still wearing the
helmet I do think he's going to lose it
at some point during the film because we
see it shattered on the ground bigger
wide shot of that first-order set and
even though there's all this red in the
background I think that's just four key
although I love totally what it implies
about the scenes that they're filming
here another trailer shot of Leia at
that console this looks like a really
badass wicked weapon that the
first-order wields this is that thing
that people were calling a space horse
so it's like a giant horse that somebody
can write more creature
behind-the-scenes that's probably one of
the other coolest things about the Star
Wars universe in the new films is that
they introduce all these other new
creatures even with force awakens all of
this water behind the scenes is from the
Ock to set it just looks like Rey is
going to be training in a lot of
different ways that you haven't seen
Jedi do before this is that casino set
in the creature that everybody was
freaking out about in that shot from
behind the scenes they released earlier
like this little guy is probably the
richest person on the planet
Lupita is Maz Kanata is back Laura
Dern's character who is part of the New
Republic our first shot of general Hux
I'm really hoping that kylo Ren actually
takes care of him during this film
Chewbacca
on what looks like one of the resistance
cruisers so it seems like at some point
ray and Luke will meet up with Leia and
the other resistance fleet and then we
finally get our first shot of phasma
she's so fantastic so much more phasma
in this film like I said John boyega was
hyping up thin versus phasma another
shot of kylo Ren without the helmet you
see the new version of the scar this is
that big wide shot that we saw in the
trailer of Basma with all the
first-order troopers this might be them
trying to hit that resistance base
because ryan johnson said that right
after the events of force awakens the
first-order goes on the offensive big
time this looks like the casino set with
somebody getting their ass handed to
them they explained that you know you
see them here and their little alien
tuxedos the casino planet is a different
side of Star Wars like the really rich
side you see the resistance everybody is
super poor they're living on what they
can but you also have other people in
the galaxy that are crazy wealthy so
you'll see a lot of that on the casino
planet and we finally see Benicio del
Toro in oh man kylo Ren training with
what looks like either other members of
the Knights of rent or this could be him
fighting Rey in Luke Skywalker
because Rey also uses a staff but so
this person here so this is more likely
Knights of Ren Finn in the casino set
just confirming that his storyline will
take him into Benicio del Toro's Paz in
oh man this looks so cool here - so ray
fighting off three people at the same
time this has got to be a bunch of
stormtroopers or Knights of Ren Finn in
what looks like either an imperial
prison or maybe prison on that casino
planet Luke and Leia together there were
a lot of people wondering if they
actually had scenes together in the
movie and they do I don't know exactly
what the scenes are but there will be a
moment where they do get to meet each
other and because Rey is in her new
costume in this it looks like it's later
in the film after she meets back up with
Finn's character so let me know what do
you guys think about this footage I
think it's great I think the way they've
been promoting it has been good - so
what will happen is there's an Avengers
infinity war panel
happening I'll do a video for that next
so that should post in a couple hours
but while you wait for everything you
can click here to rewatch the episode 7
trailer and you can click here for all
my spider-man Easter eggs thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight